hey buzz see that's me gia Gunn and I'm
here with the dolls from RuPaul's Drag
Race all-star season four
hi I'm Trinity I'm gonna lose on hello
its me Valentina its pheromone and we're
gonna take a BuzzFeed quiz to find out
which all-stars for Queen
we are who's it gonna be who's it gonna
be clay now
okay ladies question number one which
maxi pad challenge would you slay our
Champlin challenge
I never slayed a challenge so I don't
really know it's about talent no riffs
cheap Nats game no Roli no but I can't
act up at their throat oh I definitely
think I'm talent show
oh my gosh there's so many I know I'd be
gorgeous than the roof of any outfit
yep designing outfits for three
different categories I think on season
three I actually did that sickening goo
okay next up we have pick a legendary
snatch game performance Bob the drag
queen as suzhou or Carol Channing
Aquarius Melania Trump oh I love Bianca
as Judge Judy what about adore Delano as
Anna Nicole Smith wasn't that legendary
I mean it was very good I personally
liked Alaska male why me in the ass
sometimes that was good that was my
favorite and you say that all the time
well baby I don't really have many
options I'm doing Bianca Beauty honey
Judge Judy because you judgmental cuz
I'm a winner
okay let's see if I can read this which
passed extra-special guest judge would
you want to see at the judge's table I
know my answer oh who is it
Christina all day I just like seeing her
especially when she has a pink wig on
I'm picking Lady gaga because I know she
was on my season and I don't want to be
anybody on this besides me I'm gonna
save the best for last impressed Vanessa
Williams well God is a woman so I'm
choosing ariana grande
I'm gonna go with Lady Gaga as
because she was like amazing to me
you're giving she was she wrote notes
for us she was really close that was
your guys at sea yeah how was she in
touch with the ranking she's really much
she must have been filming a star is
born on that a time huh I have no idea
choose a song to lip-synch for your
legacy - and ladies and gentlemens
greedy by Irena Green Day is here so I'm
a pig that one because the wait that's
the one I was gonna choose choose it you
might end up being me it'd be great
what about stronger what doesn't kill
you by Kelly Clarkson that's Kelly
Clarkson dancing on my own
cuz I could just stand there and cry
like did you be amazing ahead of a
question how do I go back
my biggest goal for 2019 is to do songs
that I actually know the words off with
greedy by Ariana Grande okay well in
that case but I don't see twinkle
twinkle little star on here that's the
only that's the only one analytics to
maybe shake it off by Taylor Swift I
like that one well they don't have a
Britney through a song so the closest
thing is gonna be into their Rihanna
song do you like Britney I mean I don't
love her right I what's written by lip
sync - I love radar oh you're that girl
I'm gonna I'm gonna choose believe by
cher because it has the most auto-tune
in it
okay what's a classic drag phone I'm
gonna pick cut to the feeling to redeem
poor Monique arts cartwheels and wig
loss oh my god she's in the raft it's a
very good song it's a very good song
thickening all right choose an all-stars
Queens you would not send home I would
not Tatiana you just don't send home
Tatiana how come how come Roxxxy Andrews
has been on here because no one ever
ladies and gentlemen I I am gonna
definitely say who are you nursing oh my
girl my favorite girl is in this Tammy
I was gonna say I would never sell
another round
I love Tammie Browns so much I'm
obsessed with her I might work for like
that's somebody that it goes speechless
when I see the only person to choose for
me would be you know just like
Tupperware it comes in set so the only
person I would not choose this detox
okay
Oh cause y'all got the same structure
the same part I like I'm not gonna send
home my sister Kennedy Davenport
that's a Davenport nobody else did he
did some laundry she's a good dancer
next one is choosing all-star Queen to
get that chop-chop Jojo oh I know what
twin let me go oh yeah yeah I have to
choose other because that would be more
irrelevant to me being me but not
because I would yeah I'm gonna send home
ben de la creme because she I got to do
it before she sends herself home well
I'm choosing Alyssa Edwards because
she's got a show on Netflix and she's
had enough well I'm gonna be the shady
queen of the season and I'm gonna send
home deep Oh
then you just say you were not gonna
send home details yes that's not that
I'm gonna be the [ __ ] out of the lady
she was on my show like you what was the
show huh spider that's trailer blood and
and and so oh this is a really hard
question
pick it just pick it take it bite it
okay guys I'm gonna close my eyes and
just touch one okay because I don't know
I
yeah I'm the kind of three turn your
phones around one two three
Valentina
so you're perfect you're beautiful and
you look like Linda Evangelista but the
Realty is that you're one fierce queen
who isn't here to play oh my god but you
guys know you guys know what it's all
about per se that sounds just like me so
I guess I'm perfect and lovely like a
model too speaking of perfect like a
model you got me again
speaking of not looking like a model
Manila Luzon there are two words that
describe you like I could name of a
couple accent I could name a couple of
different words than what's here but
eleganza extravaganza you're an all-star
baby and you earned that title a long
time ago did you three times
honey fair and I got Latrice Royale
Latrice Royale how anyone who knows
their herstory knows that you're not
just a bold and beautiful Queen but also
one with the lovely heart of gold oh
yeah I didn't shark chunky yet funky
Valentino's you get girl you know I got
me do you know she plays this by better
huh she played it five times at home
before she got here girl just to make
sure that she got her so can I like
scroll through your nudes oh don't go
through their phone [ __ ] get out of
there all it is is like baked good oh my
god this has been so much fun thank you
so much to BuzzFeed for making this quiz
for us and be sure to catch RuPaul's
Drag Race
Allstars and
14 at ATM bye
can I just make this phone that has
baked goods everybody let my baked goods
[Music]